dude what did it feel like to have this
giant reunion moment you guys just had
right here you know it's been such a
journey with this cast and it's been
such a long time where we've been going
through this covet era so to now have a
moment like this is such a beautiful
experience yeah talk to me about what
was going through your mind when you
roll up to your season three premiere
the first one you guys have been able to
have and there's just like lines of fans
out there is this real yeah like that's
really all I can think about is is we've
been doing this for so long now and 30
episodes later to have this moment it's
such a beautiful thing so to everybody
who's still waiting to all of these
people over here I mean my heart is so
warm right now I'm so thankful so teed
up for me seasoned at the end of season
two we're on poglandia when we pick up
season three where do we go how what can
you tell me
we're going a lot of places baby it
looks like one of the most action-packed
seasons that we've had yet how can fans
like mentally prepare themselves for
where we finally end up at the finale of
season three I would say make sure you
get a lot of sleep and then dive into it
with a fresh mind but uh if you thought
season two was crazy
strap in if you had to be uh stuck on an
island with one of your cast mates who
would it be probably Rudy honestly yeah
he's from Alaska so he's got a little
you know a little wild child yeah
everybody said and he said he's always
in a hammock or he's in a tree so we're
on my way over here I pop open my
Instagram and I see that your girls
hosting it's gonna be the musical guest
on Saturday Night Live dude what does it
mean for you guys to be able to have
this these parallel career high moments
to be able to support each other through
these moments I mean she's the best and
I'm so excited for her and everything
happening in her career right now and uh
you know I'm so happy for everything
going on with me in my cast right now so
it's it's a lot of good things going on
foreign